bene a tutti ragazzi siamo parigi e
parigi iniziamo subito sposiamoci quadri
alive nuovo video bellissimo grazie ciao
ciao a tutti ragazzi veramente questo
video sono valigia e oggi siamo su trevi
a quiz dove farò io il quiz su mette
bizet ed ogni volta che sbaglierò normi
scoccheranno qualcosa addosso ci siamo
da bene cosa ma fa vigeva quanto ne so
io ragazzi sono super skillato perché ha
deciso di fare video sulle mamme perché
abbia come di cantello e ora gun
ovviamente in difficoltà è difficile ma
cosa perché mette stato sociale perché è
stato bocciato a scuola è stato bocciato
con diletta a fare i video le mamme
dyson bocciato che facevano sulle mamme
prendi buzz lightyear nova bear avevano
parole ma che cazzo è allora andiamo
iniziano a scacciare la fa ma poi mai
avere delle scarpe così brutte che cazzo
vuoi no dai schifo a perché le scarpe
perché si è anche pulita ma che pulita
fa schifo dai dai che ci sia un sorbello
la scarpa comunque mi donò allora quanti
video hanno fatto con romanzi avete
fatto vi devono trovarsi avevo 11
andiamo a comandare celine mezza la
ragazza tiene due
[Musica]
l'altro annuncio del tutto molto
interessante ha già al vero che abbiamo
dato una mano gramajo ma noi ragazzi
grazie per quanti rai che hanno fatto la
striscia depilatoria challenge milioni
inseriti ci sottragga
e allora di che cosa ci ho pensato ci ha
scritto ora sale ho comprato ma non
cucino perché non so cucinare melo
attaccate addosso l'unica attività del
sale perché masterchef siamo già lunghe
si è già messo lì si grazie
che schifo è ora che non sono per niente
sono studiato e più pignolo matteo
valentino di una dai dai sikh è vero sì
che è vero la pigna lizia pignoli ce
l'hai la faccia da pignoli m quante
visualizzazione affatto l'anguria la
ghiaccia alle lei allora lei ha ragione
milione circa 4 milioni 3 milioni 2
milioni
porca [ __ ] cazzo siete possiamo mettere
mise più di pai niente scorcio avanti
come andiamo avanti non ho mai
dimenticato lette farcela io ce l'ho io
circa perché io gli devo ricordare le
cose perché non se ne hanno le cose
migliori perché non no alla caffè perché
mi avete messo lo scotch e rosa tra
tutti perché sei molto gaio come un
sacco panda mi hai gratis
quante visualizzazione ha fatto da tag
light questo è un bordello ai quella sai
che quella di prima ha fatto 4 quindi
secondo me questo almeno 6000 telo 7
milioni chi è
sasha ha detto poi ha scherzato mandarlo
io stavo scherzando viva a scocciare lo
stesso le cose è scorretto perché è il
chip a madonna che odio profondo ragazze
ma glielo avevo già messo basta stop
esisterà un girone dell'inferno per voi
ragazzi
noi siamo bravi buoni carini cocò
monsignor che non si vede in forma
no avanti capito la gara fuori dal web
io lo so anch'io ho sbagliato di uno i
prof
un libro può mai avere sette capi zio
non è quello di virgina digilio
però hai sbagliato no no no se sarò mi
rifiuto
no io dai col demonio
no in testa una ragazza donna che o no
ragazzi non state facendo veramente
questa cosa no non avete fatto da
perdere non l'avete fatto a me faceva
male allora anch'io
matteo mi stai potendo male o no no ecco
lato difensivo di testimone
basta è che gli faccia rispondere per
una domanda e poi basta
io io sono in corato fa vicini e certe
per soprattutto sulla maglia ma
ignorante visualizzazioni ha fatto il
pach time di natale 500 mila 950 mila e
300 mila un milione un milione 950 mila
ma se sono 50mila aggiornate figlio
adesso per tra milione a un milione di
arrivare prima che reale lo so mi sta
colando tutto fino aiuti che tutto il
detersivo nel non fare è in stand by a
fermo ma non a me è ormai fa parte di
lui ha fatto soldi
[Applauso]
che appare credibile
va bene ragazzi me da bambino mi
facevano così dopo un pò datata marzo
quanti video hanno fatto con i media
non lo so raga dai 20 è fatto solo col
tecnico maran pam pam pam certo
migliorare un po ma anche a me né per
forza basta
va bene che questo io può finire qua
questo video mi è piaciuto tantissimo
melo riguarderò sempre tantissimo grazie
ammette pisa che gli invitati a casa
sono tanto contento di aver fatto questa
scelta
lasciate 100.000 aikal video passate
anche sul canale metti bce tra di dischi
cioè la casa dei ragazzi di vita
personalmente mi piace anche la risorsa
che come è ridotto dell iscrizione da
terzi fischiatemi ci vediamo il prossimo
video 321 mette b m [ __ ] tutto il
deters
aspetta perdi tu mi fai citato le
bruciava bene ma mi faceva pena è stata
la cosa più dorata e persino a chi
brucia la pelle
guarda i tipi della martire ha infatti
inserito